so I think it's really crucial that we
all understand what's going on under our
scalp because this is the mothership and
and it would explain a lot of our
behavior for example we don't have one
brain we have like three brains all
smushed under one scalp and none of them
disappeared you know they're just like
Russian dolls one inside of another it's
like a relative you can't get rid of so
and they're always arguing with each
other that's what I mean about conflict
in the brain for example the oldest
brain the brain stem is about I don't
know five hundred million years old and
it's basic it's just made sure we you
know that we eat kill and made which is
really only useful if you're working at
Goldman Sachs so then on top of that
maybe 250 million years ago we started
to get this this mammalian brain which
meant that we are we bonded with our
young rather than ate them and then only
about 500,000 years ago we got this
frontal thing and this is El Capitan oh
this is the executive brain it's in
charge of attention awareness
strategical logical rational thought
so you see why we're confused we got
three brains all squished in here so
that's probably why you get women who
like to UM who read Heidegger but also
want to screw the plumber it's a mess
now I'm not saying there's nothing we
can do but it's just kind of
understanding who's in charge if there's
nothing you can do about it because
sometimes it's survival but sometimes
you can switch that thing on in front
we're going back to mindfulness which
means you can regulate you can pull the
reins gently because you know you're
having a limbic reaction you know I want
to kill you which is one of my favorite
states because I'm addicted to my own
adrenaline this is that they forget
about coke forget about this other stuff
we're our own drug addicts you know
we're at natural-born junkies shooting
ourselves up with our own hormones it's
important again beside the brain to
understand how our hormones work because
that's what makes us feel the way we
feel and do the well like think about
sex it's okay I'll give you a human see
when you think about sex it switches on
the hormones and that's what makes the
action happen
if you don't have any hormones you can
think all you want ain't nothin gonna
happen sometimes the hormones come on
and you weren't even thinking about it
that's like when you get a stiffy in the
elevator so this this thing we have
about a hundred different hormones and
they're driving us and coming on and off
depending on which occasion for example
well I'm addicted to adrenaline
sometimes I call a taxi to take me to
the airport and when it gets to my house
I start packing I love that stuff I got
a hit in that one serotonin you know
it's a feel-good chemical these people
aren't people pleasers they don't have
to set their hair on fire to get
attention I have none of that drug I
have to buy it over a counter so it's
really understanding what mode we're in
you know what's what's what's driving us
and then of course the real go get them
the real you know makes you strive and
drive this dopamine and the kind of
problem it's it's again a backlash from
when we used to you know back in the
bush when we'd hunt for nuts or food and
we get a mouthful right
and before we swallowed we get this hit
of dopamine which made us look for
reward for nuts for later on like I'll
make it simple if I want a pair of shoes
I'm you know I'm I'm into that and I
find a pair of shoes so I get this huge
hit of dopamine and so before I even put
them on I'm already hunting for other
shoe rich environments and then I'm so
hungry to get shoes but I'm just primed
with that stuff that if I see a woman
with a pair I want I might know her
ankle off so this thing this dopamine
gets us you know it gets us jacked up to
you know get the next thing and if you
leave that switch on too long and we do
because there's always something else to
eat something else to drive something
else to snort you know we're in a
constant state of wanting wanting and
the thing about dopamine it won't just
stress you out it'll kill you I mean you
know that again we're doing this to
ourselves
there's countries being bombarded by war
and disease and we here who have
everything are killing ourselves off
with our own thoughts can you figure
that out so listen I'm not saying
dopamine's bad
we need this stuff you know it's also it
works to make us strive to make fire and
made it strive to make tools and strive
to put together a bookshelf from Ikea
made a strife but again if we're not
conscious of it it burns you out so
again I was interested if this chemical
you know all this is happening is there
a way I can intentionally take the bull
by the horns and lower this stuff in my
case when it when I get too jacked up
you know when I start the list by turtle
feed dog write this show worry bout
Ebola by Lam shapers it's always garbage
you know mixed in with what you know
feed children I get obsessed once I
bought a hundred and fifty blue and
white striped cushions obsessed and III
it was on a nautical website for like
five days and then they were much
smaller when I got him you know that in
the picture a size of a leaf toilet
paper and now my house is full what am I
doing with them it's the Odette dopamine
took over so suddenly blue and what when
the blue and white striped cushions I
had no more air space anymore I started
with the carpets that's the nature of
human beings I can't whip myself so I
wanted to find some way I could you know
I could get first of all maybe cut out
some of those critical thoughts and also
learn some way I could you know pull
those chemicals out so that's when I was
interested in studying mindfulness based
cognitive therapy because that certainly
is a way where you don't need to run to
a shrink now you're responsible for your
own brain
you